give us a Rick yeah geez Morty I'm gonna
[ __ ] slit your throat give us a Marty
oh geez Rick why are you trying to slit
my throat mr. Lemongrab
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you get in here get the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] you what are you
doing here my place what are you doing
in my place get the [ __ ] out of here get
out of here hard this is hard for me I
don't like people in my place I don't
like these people around me get out of
my world
give me my goggles put my goggles down
get the [ __ ] out listen man you're just
a product of this machine you know at
least that's how I feel I'm the product
of this machine so turns away commentary
for where he is in the game alright this
is the office yeah he's in the office
yeah he's gonna he's gonna right now
he's looking for the take he's he's he's
like it's right next to the
the numbers anyway then so he needs to
have the numbers by here that's a no
there's done it he's got a cannon now
the thing is you get a special prize in
this level if you throw the numbers
binder into the open desk job in the
fact it's a real secret yeah and also
that number binder is filled with
numbers yeah I mean just play you like
if you if you hit it in those right
numbers like a whole load of numbers
appear one through nine and zero is that
beautiful and but you only have one shop
what uh what wheat what we what we
realized was that there's only really
ten numbers zero through nine and it's
like and then we were just like oh
there's only 10 of these and then and
and it's crazy to think there's only ten
numbers but it's true so that was one of
the things like you'll see it repeated
in this level all over the places lends
numbers you see it on the calculator
there we go
you'll see in the numbers book and it's
fascinating you know it's one of those
things not a lot of people know about
under the plant it's under the plant
under the plant there you go listen
[ __ ] were the toughest [ __ ]
around you got that yeah that's right we
eat dicks for breakfast don't wait don't
wait you said it man we're a gang nobody
goes [ __ ] yeah man who can talk [ __ ] to
us know why we're [ __ ] bad baddest
[ __ ] around
[Music]
hold on we got a new gang recruit will
come Scudder go we'll call this person
scooter cooter
goody you wanna join our gang you gotta
be [ __ ] you gotta be willing to do
[ __ ] up alright yeah you gotta prove
how [ __ ] up you are to us all right
over to us homeboy how [ __ ] up you are
if you want to join us
come on homeboy you gotta do [ __ ] up
things man tuff you can't just sit
around and be I can't be a normal person
baked are in this will surely get
scooter in the gang we did the ritual
all wrong we summoned a regular person
it's not Satan we did the wrist I know
we can do it no we have no idea what
we're doing we're so bad we just
summoned a regular person we never we
never had something and that was like
two ways we like
that we we moved a couple things around
I like we had like we had some jokes
which will harsh us in the original in
the in like our original like [ __ ]
documents to this like we had a section
where the character way you had a
character where you interest me [ __ ] land
you know we had a segment while like you
were eating little people and like oh
yeah that's right I forgot about that
was like jerking off whole life somebody
look like he was joking eating little
like we didn't like cut that because it
was too offensive it was just it was
like but like you found a better waste I
mean you know we were like there's
enough come like cups of coming in real
life in our lives we don't need it yeah
I don't need this in the game because I
have to deal with we wanted to create an
experience to get away from all the cups
of come that we are just always around
us in our normal lives
Jesus Christ you just murder two
Oh
[Music]
let's find out what's inside this pillow
come on we're going to find out get it
there's something in here I just have a
feeling okay ready let's do this okay
whoa whoa something's gotta be here
there's something inside huh oh whoa
whoa whoa what the hell whoa now we're
talking well it is knows what sites
outta here oh look look wait wait wait
wait look look look you can unravel it
oh wait
Oh what is that what's up [ __ ] hell
we were this is oh my god oh look at all
this week there's something in here
there's something weird
what wait wait I feel like God I got it
[ __ ] in here it's a coin it's us serving
the city why would that be in here is
what I found in this pillow ESX
city of Manteca 100 years serving the
city of Manteca 1918 to 2018 all jumping
the gun a little bit not 2018 yet you
should put it back I should put it back
hit it head up buddy the coin back in
zip it up
I'm keep I'm gonna keep the coin and
then we're gonna go ahead and put this
back you know we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna do little kids at home as
you're watching if you do this
just see what we're doing now put it
back and sew it up teamwork you take a
lot of times when you're making a game
yet you have to take the thing out of
the pillowcase metaphorically speaking
and then you find the coin he will find
a kiss nice little shape Morty come here
tell you a secret
what is it Rick
[Music]
[ __ ] robot she's not real this you
were made into test tube oh Jesus is
canon spoiler alert